Now that Spider-Man: Homecoming's home entertainment
release is out, there's a stack of bonus material
including new deleted scenes and footage.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and today I'm revealing some very cool Spider-Man
Homecoming deleted scenes and explaining some
of the easter eggs and missing details we
never got to see in the theatrical release.
I'm also starting a new Funko Pop giveaway
on this video and for a chance to win, make
sure you're subscribed to my channel and leave
a comment below with your thoughts on the
deleted scenes or anything Marvel.
Quick warning, obviously there are spoilers
ahead for anyone who's not yet seen the movie.
The first deleted scene on the digital release
comes via an extended director's cut of Peter
Parker's vlog-style behind-the-scenes video
of what happened on his trip to Berlin during
the events of Captain America: Civil War.
The extended version includes some great additional
footage of what Peter got up to the night
after the airport battle in Berlin when he
was so hyped up that he decided to put on
his Spidey suit and go partying in the German
capital.
"I should really go to bed, but I don't want
to."
"Shhh."
This additional footage of Spider-Man swinging
between buildings with a girl explains set
photos that emerged during the movie's production
which showed Spider-Man swinging from a helicopter
as he looked to be saving a red-haired girl,
which at the time led to some speculation
that Mary Jane was going to appear in the
movie.
The extra footage also seems like a fun way
for the movie to pay homage to the web-slinging
superhero from Sam Raimi's trilogy who swung
between New York skyscrapers with ease, which
was something the filmmakers otherwise made
a conscious decision to step away from in
Homecoming.
And that might be the reason this scene ended
up being deleted because Tom Holland's Spider-Man
in both Civil War and Homecoming hasn't yet
mastered all his abilities and actually finds
it pretty scary when he has to scale the Washington
Monument, so including scenes of him happily
swinging through Berlin might have felt inconsistent
with his character at this point.
It's still a shame we couldn't see this cut
though as it also finishes with a funny scene
where Peter gets busted by Happy Hogan who
discovered what he got up to thanks to the
front pages of a German newspaper.
And that feels like a nice way to end the
scene especially given that the filmmakers
set up Peter's vlog as an updated take on
his photojournalism in the comics and previous
movies.
After the school bus leaves for the Academic
Decathlon, it passes by a road sign that reads
"Triskelion Cleanup", a little easter egg
to the SHIELD headquarters located on Theodore
Roosevelt Island in Washington DC.
The building was severely damaged during the
final showdown between HYDRA and SHIELD in
Captain America: The Winter Soldier and there's
a deleted scene in Homecoming which revisits
the damaged site.
In the scene, Peter, Ned and Michelle see
the damaged Triskelion building as the school
bus drives over a bridge.
"Oooh, what is going on?"
"Damage control."
"They're still cleaning up from when Captain
America took down those Skycrap carriers for
no reason."
"I'm pretty sure Cap was just trying to save
us from tyranny."
"Eh.
That's what they want you to think."
It's a humorous moment that shows how different
characters in the MCU view Captain America.
Ned thinks he's a hero, but Michelle is way
more sceptical.
This would have been an interesting easter
egg to include but it looks like it was likely
cut for time, which will have also saved a
little cash as the CGI for the damaged Triskelion
building wasn't completed.
By the way, the scene also included a little
joke about Thor not having a phone, a nice
nod to the funny moment in the Thor mockumentary
where Thor complains to Bruce Banner about
Tony Stark and Captain America not asking
him to help out with Civil War.
"Was that Tony Stark?"
"No."
"Was that Thor?"
"Nooo.
I don't think Thor uses a phone."
"Good point."
"Here, talk to Thor."
"Yep."
"He's been sorta waiting to hear from you."
"I have him right here."
"Oh you can't right now."
"He doesn't know how to get in touch with
you."
"I don't have a phone."
"He doesn't have a phone."
"Send a raven."
Homecoming already teased the existence of
Miles Morales in the MCU in the scene where
Donald Glover's character Aaron Davis gets
caught by Spidey in a car park and mentions
he has a nephew in the neighbourhood.
But there's a little extra footage of Donald
Glover that makes the existence of Miles Morales
even clearer.
"Excuse Me!"
"A human being needs help."
"Yeah, sorry Miles.
I ... I'm not gonna make it.
Yeah I'm just stuck."
If this moment was meant to complete the movie's
scene with Glover, I can see why it was cut
as it slows down the film's momentum just
for the sake of making a more obvious reference
to Miles Morales.
However, I wonder if it might have originally
been planned as a humorous extra post- or
mid-credits scene?
In the comics, Davis is the uncle of Miles
Morales who, like Peter Parker, was bitten
by a radioactive spider turning him into a
famous web-crawling superhero.
Miles Morales will be getting his own animated
Spider-Man movie released by Sony, however,
the Morales easter eggs in Homecoming could
also be setting up a possible appearance in
the MCU somewhere down the line.
Talking of possible deleted after-credit scenes,
it looks like the Vulture's mid-credits scene
was cut back as Laura Harrier who played Adrian
Toomes' daughter, Liz, has revealed that she
filmed a scene where she meets her father
in prison.
If you notice, the mid-credits scene actually
finished with a prison guard calling out to
the Vulture that his family had arrived to
see him.
"Toomes!
Your family is here."
This is interesting because Harrier has said
she wishes the scene had been included and
she's also said that she'd like to see her
character Liz get powers as she does in the
Ultimate comics as the superhero Firestar.
In fact, I wonder whether that additional
moment in the mid-credits scene could have
set that up in some way?
There was only a little bit of footage from
the Midtown High School news channel in the
final cut of Homecoming.
"This past weekend, Midtown's academic decathlon
team defeated the country's best to win the
national championship."
"Later that day they also defeated death."
"As you know we made out alive and that's
the important thing."
"Couldn't bear to lose a student on a school
trip."
"Not again."
But there's a load more additional news channel
footage with Betty and Jason that we never
got to see.
It's got plenty more hilariously awkward lines
and deliberately bad editing, but interestingly,
it also includes some easter eggs and additional
info on small plot points from the movie.
"Questions remain this morning as authorities
piece together the alarming events at this
weekend's homecoming dance."
"An unidentified male individual assailant
was taken into custody after police found
him attached to the side of a bus with Spider-Man
webs."
"OK"
"To those of you ..."
"To those of you who took inappropriate selfies
with the perpetrator webbed to the bus, you
have 24 hours to remove them from all your
social media accounts."
At the end of that clip, we can see that Tiny,
one of Peter's classmates, is now in possession
of Shocker's gauntlet, which it looks like
he nabbed from the villain after Spider-Man
webbed Shocker to a school bus during their
fight in the movie.
This moment could just be a bit of fun or
it might tease Tiny's character actually using
this high-tech weapon in the sequel, especially
given that, in the comics, Tiny has been known
to bully Peter.
"In sports ... the girls basketball team takes
on the Flatbush Asgardians this Thursday night."
"Let's show our tiger pride."
"Go get 'em tigers!"
"Roar."
The Flatbush Asgardians is an amusing Thor
easter egg which shows that Thor and the Asgardians
seem to be quite popular on Earth now.
We already saw a curious reference to Thor
in the final movie in the shape of the Korean
Church of Asgard which was next to the Thai
restaurant where May and Peter ate.
And, of course, Betty's "Go get 'em, tigers"
is a nice easter egg to MJ's "Go get 'em,
tiger" which she said to Peter Parker at the
very end of Spider-Man 2.
There's another funny segment called "Under
The Mask" which speculates on the real identity
of Spider-Man.
"Up next on Under The Mask, who is Spider-Man?"
"Who is Spider-Man?"
"I dunno who he is, but I have my suspicions."
"It's a mystery, always will be!"
Michelle has her suspicions, which implies
she thinks it's someone she knows, and at
the end of the movie, she joked that she thought
Peter was hiding something, so I'm thinking
this is quite likely a tease to her uncovering
Peter's secret identity in the sequel.
"Don't forget today's Sokovian Relief lunch."
"Enjoy a $5 all-you-can-eat paprikash buffet."
"All proceeds go to charity."
This clip gives us two tasty call-backs to
MCU movies.
First of all, it's clear that there are ongoing
efforts to raise money to help Sokovia after
the destructive events of Avengers: Age of
Ultron.
And secondly, the paprikash meal the school
canteen is serving is a nice nod to the dish
that Vision prepared for Wanda in Captain
America: Civil War, and, remember, that Wanda
herself also originates from Sokovia.
Happy Hogan gets a short comedic deleted scene
where he calls up his mother after he's finished
arranging the move of Avengers tech to the
the team's new facility.
"Yeah, hey ma."
"Yeah, it's Harold."
"Yeah, it's done."
"Yeah, Tony trusted me and I took care of
it."
"Me.
Yeah mom me.
Is that so hard to believe?"
"That I could accomplish something.
I ..."
"I'll call you back."
It looks like this cut scene is trying to
build up some backstory for Happy in the MCU,
showing how he feels he has to prove himself
to his mum.
And while it's humorous, I can understand
why this moment was probably cut for time;
after all, it doesn't add an awful lot and
may have even undercut the drama of the fight
scene going on in the cargo plane at the same
time.
There are a few other deleted scenes which,
although mildly interesting, were likely trimmed
to avoid padding out the final cut which was
already over 2 hours.
One is an additional scene where Peter's classmates
try to convince him to go to the Academic
Decathlon.
"You can't bail a week before nationals.
We don't have anyone as strong as you in physics."
"But you have Flash!"
"You got me!"
"Everyone prefers Peter!"
"Yeah."
"Look, they're not gonna do a physics challenge
2 years in a row."
"Guys I'm sorry.
I gotta ... Guys!"
"Screw you!"
"You suck!"
"Seriously"
I'm glad this was cut as it doesn't add much
compared to the better paced scene of the
decathlon team practising which introduced
each of Peter's classmates in a much funnier,
more interesting way.
Other scenes cut to trim the fat include various
moments of Spider-Man running and swinging
around Brooklyn; a scene of Adrian Toomes
on the phone to his daughter Liz; and a scene
of Peter and Ned doing their secret handshake
on the street again.
Captain America's PSAs were something a lot
of fans enjoyed and there are many more which
aren't on the digital release, but which are
expected on the Blu-ray, including one about
brushing your teeth.
In the meantime, there's an additional one
about hot lunches that wasn't included in
the movie but is on the blooper reel.
"Hi, I'm Captain America, whether you're a
student or a soldier, there's one thing that
will give you an edge, a hot lunch!"
Now, what do you think of those deleted scenes
and do you wish any had been included in the
film?
And which of the upcoming Marvel movies are
you most excited about?
Let me know what you think in the comments
section and don't forget to subscribe for
a chance to win an awesome Spider-Man Funko
Pop.
I'll be announcing the winner in an upcoming
video, so do hit the bell to get notifications
for all my new videos.
Your support is hugely appreciated, as always,
and if you enjoyed this make sure you leave
a like and check out more of my Marvel and
deleted scenes videos right here.
Congratulations to the three winners of my
Kingsman merch giveaway, who are on screen
now.
If that's you, make sure you contact me so
I can get your details to send you the prize.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!